herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
ein tag persönlicher kaufleute heute
koche ich für damon wie ihr sehen ist
echt nicht hier bei mir in der küche in
knight day bis in unserem büro ihr habt
richtig gehört die haben gemeinsam ein
büro tätig und falls ihr euch fragt
warum damit ich mehr videos für euch
machen kann nicht nur noch einmal die
woche auch wenn das wie immer viel
arbeit ist aber erich hat sich von mir
french toast zum frühstück gewünscht und
die werde ich jetzt machen und leute ist
wäre jan ist ein tag persönlicher kopf
wenn ich einfach nur french toast machen
würde dementsprechend machen damit es
ein bisschen abwechslungsreicher ist und
es nicht nur süß frühstück das früher
einmal hat mit bacon da für mich war den
rufen vorgeheizt ich will mich noch mit
der fahne machen aber das ist voll
ihr wisst ja dass das gut funktioniert
von meinem brt video wird santander
welche jetzt mal noch besser rein legen
können und dann leute meine geheime
zutat für die french toast wirklich
macht sie so viel besser es heißt ja
french toast na also man würde denken
man macht es mit gewöhnlichem toastbrot
ich kann nur so viel sagen wenn man die
french toast mit brioche macht also mit
französischen brot es ändert alles das
macht das ganze viel krasser viel besser
viel lecker und alles was man mit viel
sagen kann also fangen wir an und machen
die mischungen die wir gleich das brot
tunken auch wie ist wieder sehr einfach
wir brauchen eine schüssel milch und
eier zeigen wir hier 120 milliliter mehr
so viel ungefähr dann wie gesagt etwas
sind aber nicht so viel wie schmeckte
sehr intensiv und da kommen natürlich
noch ein bisschen zucker dazu
nur zwei teelöffel ich habe zwar vor das
ganze vielleicht mit einem teller zu
servieren aber es kann trotzdem die
chance packen sie mir schon fremd aus
klingt so unfassbar fans ich finde das
klingt so richtig nach so einem
frühstück in so einem guten hotel so
fremd ich muss das ganze noch etwas teil
weil ich darf auch noch einen kaffee
mitbringen will der regel sieht schonmal
gut ausgehe jetzt weiß ich seit einem
museum fährt ein bisschen ferien am
liebsten will ich butter dafür nehmen
aber ich habe vergessen welche zu kaufen
die besonderheit vom radsport ist das
wirklich richtig flach ist früher ganze
nochmal um das legen wir das einfach
hier einst lassen das bisschen vorsorgen
wenn das gleich und damit angewachsen
war schnell das frühe 1
dann drehen sie jetzt hier das brio es
hat sich komplett voll gesaugt wird auch
wie gesagt beide seiten kommt nicht voll
sind jetzt gehen wir das ganze einfach
solange dies ist in die ferien ein
natürlich sagen und für zwei weitere
seien damit das ist ja noch recht und es
hier schön goldgelb von beiden seiten
das früher wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
nachgegangen wird dies jetzt schon mal
von der hitze leute ich freue mich freue
mich auch für data ist es sogar das
würde auch nicht mehr live and stripes
immer so schön sieht es auch wachs und
hallo liebe zuschauer
wundert euch nicht über diesen müll hier
das ist das gut so denn hier traurig
frühstück kommt an den arbeitsplatz dazu
gibt es natürlich absoluter traum und
er schaffte später kaffee und visionär
spät und ich haben wie sie richtig
gefreut
also erstmal vielen vielen dank die
große schwachstelle wird an allen
frühstücken in köln ist immer der kaffee
wenn doktor kran an der kaffeemaschine
steht dann ist mir klar dass das nur vom
allerfeinsten sorte sein können
[Musik]
okay da ich würde sagen so lässt sich
frühstücken
ich wünsche den besten appetit ich bin
gespannt dankte der wehr wieder
transport mit dem ganzen zug getragen
aber studie mal und war zuerst seit ich
dann sehr wahrscheinlich ist es
andersrum schlagern wie man will
menschen müssen wissen date ist halt
franzose und ich spreche kein wort
französisch
ja aber ich sag sie nicht mehr weil es
sehr sehr gut schmeckt french toast hat
man häufig nicht im kopf wenn man
irgendwas sich zu essen machen will aber
es ist eigentlich ein so einfaches ding
was so geil ist ich richtig froh dass
mir das eingefallen ist als ich gestern
essen bei dir bestellt also worauf kann
man trotzdem drehen damit die leute
wissen dass ich egal ob die schnecken
die ist auch viel sagen wir sehen uns
gleich die bewertungen wieder
das ist alles auf gespeist bis auf dem
weg indem ich in unterhose versteckt
dabei ich nicht mehr schaffe also
erstmal würde ich mir gerne punkte dafür
geben was ich an french toast gedacht
habe weil das war wirklich mega gut und
das war für mich eine absolute zehn von
zehn weiter zum einen mit bacon es ist
max standard ding das hat er hunderte
male gemacht dass sitzt ein paar sodann
macht ja nix falsch es wurde geliefert
und deswegen würde ich allgemein
vielleicht einen punkt abziehen und
wahrscheinlich noch einen punkt ab denn
ich weiß wie gut max kaffee sein kann
der war heute weil er nicht mit super
film microphone deswegen gebe ich dem
frühstück insgesamt nur acht von zehn
okay leute acht von zehn ist auf jeden
fall eine solide bewertung für den tages
anfangen das lässt raum zur verbesserung
und ich sagte beck beim mittagessen und
abendessen legen wir noch eine schippe
drauf dann springen wir einfach direkt
so mittagessen damit das tier nicht
gerechnet
lasst uns loslegen ich weiß nicht ob sie
es vielleicht an den zutaten schon
erkennen könnt vielleicht auch hier dann
aber wir machen tacos und nicht
irgendwelche tabus sondern crunchy tacos
liebe ich seitdem ich das mal in der
grundschule auf dem ausflug gesetzt habe
um so mehr freue ich mich dass selbst
sich das heute von mir gewünscht hat
würde sagen wir reden nicht lange herum
sondern fangen erfahren ihr seht schon
das wären tagaus mit rinder gehackte wir
fangen aber an mit dem salat salat
wollen wir nur so ungefähr den mittleren
teil mit gitarrist und den schneiden wir
dann schön feiern so vielleicht darf ein
sehr sehr scheint wird am ende einfach
nur schön auch unsere tacos um
draufgelegt als hätten wir schon mal
weiter geht es mit den tomaten kleine
vorne und hinten ab und schneiden so
halben zentimeter dicke scheiben auch
die wir wiederum dürfen
ein bisschen salz pfeffer darüber dass
mir den spaß hier müssen wir aber nur
wenn wir die ansonsten meist für steht
da jetzt leute machen wir unsere
gewürzmischung weil wir nehmen natürlich
keine gekaufte wir brauchen zwei
esslöffel kreuz damit findet das nicht
so mexikanisch preises nur zwei teilen
erste paprikapulver und dann für die
schärfe noch ein wenig so eine heimat
finden dazu gibt es noch ein bisschen
frisch gemahlenem pfeffer wirklich
specialist und das können wir so etwas
mal die seite stellt seite auch schon
mal in die mitte vor davon schneide ich
einfach nur so kleine schreibt also
erstmal oben und es ab dann jetzt
einfach zu klein hacken welche lassen
sich einfach am besten grüber / ich habe
ein bisschen gefehlt ja nur eine
hinbekommen außerdem geraten wir das
fleisch damit ist schöneres tarom abgibt
in einem topf der dämlichen die carbon
also fahne ist mit geschichte machte
danach ich auch diese chips hier
gefunden
wenn man herausfinden wie scharf sie
sind wo wir die meisten kern heraus zu
bekommen ist aber längst nicht alles so
wie man ein bisschen schon am anfang
nicht zu viel davon
hallo es dürftig diesen 20 minuten zu
tisch bitten dann macht den fehler
kleine eigentlich wollte ich diesen
costa käse also den klassischen
mexikanischen käse benutzen
den gibt es nur leider nicht besonders
gut schneidet dann würden die leute der
topf ist schönheit geht ein klein
bisschen bratfett hinein und darauf
kommt jetzt das rindfleisch das vibrato
ist es angebracht ist
es hat aufgehört zu psychischen jetzt
denken wir mal die seiten und nachdem
wir das ganze einmal gewendet haben
kommen jetzt unsere gewürze dazu
wir einmal schön ein und es hat sofort
diesen klassischen pacus gebucht das hat
einfach der kreuzkümmel hitze wissen
runter jetzt lassen wir es einfach
stehen und wir geben zu dem ganzen damit
es nicht trocken bleibt ein erster für
tomate noch dazu ich packe schon mal die
tragschicht akkus aus weil die mieten im
blech in den ofen zu fünf minuten oder
so noch geiler erst gewesen wenn es
diese kleinen tacos beim einem
supermarkt in die mitte
dann hätte man nämlich die weichen tacos
in knusprig backen können es noch geiler
aber wenn ihr einfach hier sind die
guten bilder und hier ist alles andere
sieht traumhaft aus leute so richtig
fresh ein special über syriens ist nicht
explizit ich bin da leute wir machen die
ersten zwei akkus für dave mit schnappen
wir uns hier raus ich in serie ist und
füllen sie mit dem rindfleisch und
holzprodukte wurzeln wenn dieser noch
mal rein kommen wir zu heiße numero uno
es gibt natürlich noch nachschlag für
die stimmung ist sehr gut so darauf
kommt herr peter käser selbst käse sour
cream auf jeden fall einen ordentlichen
laden locken moly auf jeden fall macht
man einfach alles könnte man sich dann
gewesen so jemanden zu haben der
änderung im alltag gekocht wenn das
irgendwann mal jemand nicht sagt bei
nachfolge damals mir sein
[Musik]
endlich eine wunderbaren frühstücks darf
nicht fehlen natürlich sour cream
limette und die spicy schärfe im fleisch
man merkt halt dass die sachen die du
geschnitten hat auch gerade erst
geschnitten wurden also dass alles so
turbo fresh nicht wie wenn man in so ein
imbiss geht wo die sachen hat schon so
einen halben tag rumliegen richtig kann
das ist dir schmecken ich mache mir auch
eine portion welche kann es kaum noch
erwarten sodass aus und dann sehen wir
unsere bewertung also ich denke ehrlich
das war der reinste traum ich weiß nicht
also ich habe selten in meinem leben
packen gegessen weil immer wenn ich im
leben bin groß mexikanisches essen
gibt's reichlich er zum horizont aber
das war wirklich der motto der beste tag
um den titel ist zum einen bei wie ich
ihnen gesagt habe die sachen waren alle
super frisch geschnitten es war komplett
frisch mit max liebe gemacht und ich
konnte halt nachträglich nach dem ersten
tag und noch mal umgestellt mehr sour
cream weniger block a mole mehr schärfen
ich komme mir den hals komplett selber
zusammenbauen kurz vor allem dass ihr
benutzten den extra tabasco und wie geht
es deinem und es wird immer besser aber
nach wie vor schlecht
ich danke während du jetzt ein mund
abkühlt würde ich sagen springen wir zum
abendessen nein wir sprechen erst mal zu
meiner bewertung unter die latte 10 von
10 für die zwei wunderbare mittag ist
ich weiß es ist riesig weil du jedes mal
so gut bewertet wird ist aber noch jung
ich sage das nicht wegen des videos zwar
der beste den ich je gegessen habe und
deswegen danke dir okay leute wir sehen
uns beim abendessen diesmal wirklich
jahres unterlagen testen dave ich hinter
der kamera denn es geht übertrieben
schnell was wir jetzt vor allem
sandwiches käse drauf ist ein wilder
ritt sandwiches mit dem sei dankbar dass
er sich das zum abend ist ein gewünscht
aber irgendwie bin ich mega fertigwaren
aufwendigere sachen gemacht aber deshalb
anhalt kommt wir brauchen den steilsten
amerikanischen mythos das ist wirklich
sehr wichtig weil bei diesem essen geht
es auch mal wieder nicht darum gesund zu
sein oder sonst was gesund hatten wir
einigermaßen heute mittag bis brauchen
nicht mehr
wir brauchen im american sandwiches wir
brauchen butter käse und noch ne kuh ist
wie bestreichen die toastscheiben von
allen seiten mit botschaften wie
sandwiches auf eine grillplatte machen
die ich natürlich auch normalerweise
meine smash burger mache dadurch habe
die hitze noch gleichmäßigen abrieb
ich glaube der käse schmilzt dann auch
besser du kannst ja schon mal ein
zwischenfazit ziehen wie wie läuft es
bei dir was kommt morgen eigentlich bei
ihr für ein video also erstmal absoluter
traum wirklich dieses bekocht werden
hatten wir an dem tag heute super viel
organisiert gedreht das eine wirklich
eine menge menge zeit erspart und das
war ein absoluter traum wenn ich aber
den ganzen tag versucht durch mathematik
ein casino auszutricksen und auch das
funktioniert hat oder nicht seit dem
morgen bei mir auf den konzernen sie
wird jetzt muss ich nur die käse
scheiben toastbrot gerecht schneiden
mussten auto ist muss diese kombination
sind billiger junger kader unseren
herzhafter der gouda daher schön flüssig
wie ein alter profi schneidet die
quadrate augenmaß aus dem käse
herauskommt nummer eins stets nur die
seite denn wir hatten den käse erst
drauf wenn ich sandwiches aufliegen und
ich habe diese oft heilbar letzte
vogelsberg aber ordentlich tempo
[Musik]
ist das ganze ja noch was zu ziehen
damit der käse auch wirklich
durchschnitts käse ksc mal noch mehr
merkte dass leute man kann nicht einfach
so nehmen würde alles einfach perfekt
zusammen klicks
[Musik]
das abendessen was aber weil wir
natürlich von etwas begleitet werden
muss
kohle wenn ich es wenn ich es nicht
besser wissen und wirst du dass er
amerikanische die american dream etwas
geschichtsträchtiges ist mit dem heute
mehr verbinden
dann würde ich denke dass wir haben ein
floppy cola pepsi cola und decoder ja
dann wenn sie mobil sind und dass da
muss man auch nicht so darf nicht so
gentle mit sein da muss man so ja ja ja
cola mit rich information mayo und
ketchup sagen
nach zehn stunden büro ist so nicht hey
leute das hört man sich doch gerne
anfangen mit so wenig aufwand ich hab
das rezept noch ein bisschen getrübt ist
ein bisschen besser als sonst macht sich
schon mal bezahlt ich würde sagen leute
das war mir eine freude die ich als gast
zu haben ist gerne in ruhe auf wir sehen
uns nächsten sonntag wieder mit einer
besonderen folgen kann ich schon mal
sagen und wir sehen uns dann macht's gut
studium